easy and I've had an argument but the
feminists I've met have an entirely
different take on domestic violence
[Music]
on the whole issue of domestic violence
that's just another word really that's a
clean up word about wife beating because
that's really what it is or Dating
Violence and it's not girls that are
beating up on boys it's boys that are
beating up on girls and using violence
to intimidate and to control and we have
very few what's called domestic violence
shelters which are places that women can
leave their home with their children and
get a new start get out of the violence
but they're not nearly enough of them we
need more funding and more resources
because it it is a tremendous
disadvantage for women and girls
[Music]
in 2014 the CDC released a report
revealing that over 5.4 million men and
4.7 million women had been victims of
intimate partner physical violence
within the previous 12 months
but then why does the media paint
domestic violence as a women's issue
the World Health Organization says one
in three women are abused by their
partner one in three American women
experiences domestic violence or
stalking at some point in her life and
when it was addressed as a men's issue
the speaker's point was that it's a
men's issue because men are the problem
I'm going to share with you a paradigm
shifting perspective on the issues of
gender violence I don't see these as
women's issues that some good men help
out with in fact I'm going to argue that
these are men's issues why is domestic
violence still a big problem in the
United States and all over the world
what's going on why do so many men abuse
physically emotionally and other
verbally in other ways the women and
girls and the men and boys that they
claim to love what's going on with men
let's Grant every single empirical case
as being true yes it is true let's just
say I mean it is not true but let's just
assume that that there is gender
symmetry in gen in domestic violence
that women as men as much as men hit
whatever if if I were to say that I
would say and therefore we need
boatloads more funding for domestic
violence to develop
there's domestic violence hustlers
it's the same thing
that's why they have to hate men it's
it's a oh my God I just this just
clicked
that's why
that's why they have to paint men it's a
problem
because remember they're always selling
a solution that's what they're doing and
so they have to keep saying that men are
like men men are like the toxic this
that because they're selling you a
solution and even this that's why they
paint men as evil and the bad guys
because they're trying to get funding
and that
wow I've seen this documentary before
but I I've never put that together as
like domestic violence Hustlers that's
what they're doing
wow that's crazy
it's like the same it's the same pattern
it is
what it is my burn
oh oh you okay and itches I can't
scratch you
I don't get it
what if I did what I was like I'd be
like they're they're there yeah
Equity intervention because this is
hidden epidemic of men who are being
beaten up by women
or I could say as the men's Rights
Movement therefore we shouldn't have
these shelters and we shouldn't fund
them because the women are all lying
well it seems to me that if you really
believe in gender symmetry it's not that
you want to you're not questioning the
number of women you're just saying the
number of men is suck you would want to
join with women who are anti-violence to
say we have a real problem here you know
it's not even a gender problem it's a
problem of women hitting men and many
women we've got to get boatloads more
funding let's work together
that seems The Logical response to this
but instead they're saying it's like a
zero-sum game if if we fund the women
then we're going to ignore the matter
well we're not we're not going to ignore
the women because we've all agree that
the levels are as high as we say
but it does sound like a zero-sum game
when only women are receiving services
in domestic violence situations
and of all the men's rights activists
I've met none of them questioned the
number of female victims but they are
calling attention to the high number of
male victims that are being dismissed
so why aren't men's rights activists and
feminists working together
[Music]
and we'll briefly said something that
made me wonder he said it would no
longer be a gender problem if both men
and women were equally victims of
domestic violence
is that why the number of male victims
are never addressed
to me it's been fraud for all this
why is it we have this enormous
economical feminist movement and
virtually nothing for men
originally it was capitalism was the big
enemy in the 60s and 70s and it was the
radical feminists in America they moved
the goal posts they said no it's no
longer capitalism it's the enemy the
enemy is patriarchy oh man
foreign
and that's how the women's movement
began and it was enormously successful
the new mood in in the refuges was going
to be that no men could work in refugees
and caught today they can't sit on the
boards and boys over nine or possibly 12
can't go into refuges or you call them
shelters their mothers have to make
other arrangements for them which I find
shocking
and it ring fenced money
I think that that particular time when
the feminist movement were desperate for
funding because they'd run out of of
publicity
and they were desperate for funding and
they needed a just cause
and unfortunately it fell into their
laps it's an enormous industry I mean
violence against women they get
something like was a billion and over a
year you hear that yeah a billion and
over that's why
so they have to sell them out as being
awful because they're they're losing
their jobs and they gotta get paid
that's sad oh my God
you're blessing you good
he's asleep
let's see if you wanted food
an awful lot of that goes on really
supposedly rehabilitating men but
essentially punishing them there's
something that's called the Duluth model
Duluth power and control will you guys
know about that no
I'll give you a copy you know in 1977 I
think a bunch of crazy women up in
Duluth Minnesota figured out they had
the solution to domestic violence and it
was all about patriarchy and all about
men
and it's a little power and control oil
because men are all about power and
control
of course not you ladies you guys you
don't control anything you have no power
you're just sweet and innocent little
things okay
so on this power control wheel is
divided up in all these things you know
about who does this and who does that
blah blah blah of course it's all men
yeah
pause for a second hold on guys I'm
gonna see what they want to eat
sometimes
water
[Music]
you can order something for him
[Music]
the entire domestic violence industry
was founded on that I think it's still
37 or 32 states the United States that
by law they have to use the Duluth model
for better Innovation programs and it's
all shame blaming yield driven
if you're a man he walk in you must
admit you did it up front or you're in
denial there's no debate there's no
discussion there's no possibility that
you could be
I only brought bought one falsely
accused the criminal justice system
could have made a mistake none
whatsoever you are to stay denial and
you will complete that course or you're
going to go to jail
you will be re-engineered
[Music]
frightening yes that's right I think
it's terrifying
absolutely terrifying
all I had to die a simple choice I could
just say yes you're right men are the
enemy
no problem but I couldn't I absolutely
couldn't
[Music]